فعلها المسلسل الشهير ذا سمسمز مره اخرى
توقعا اخر يحدث خاصه بترشحي الرئيس
الامريكي السابق ترامب وهو الذي رشح نفسه
للرئاسه في 2024 هكذا اظهر في عام 2000
لكن هل انتهى سباق ترامب الرئاسي قبل ان
يبدا الرئيس السابق رفض نصيحه فريقه بعدم
الاعلام حتى ظهور كل نتائج الانتخابات
النصفيه في مجلس الشيوخ والاعاده في
جورجيا في السادس من ديسمبر فهل علمت
ترامب قبل الاعلان بالعثرات امامه
اولها ازمه الوثائق التي عين لها مدعام
للاشراف على تحقيقاته وزاره العدل جاك
سميث كان مختصر ابي جرائم الحروب
التي كان لها لمنافسه السابق وربما
المحتمل الرئيس الحالي هناك من يمشي البيت
الابيض
ترامب الذي يلقي اليوم اول خطاب له منذ
اعلان يترشح امام مجموعه من كبار الشخصيات
في الحزب الجمهوريه دون انه مدرك مداره
خسر كثيرا من الداعمين وهذه عقبه ثانيه
امام ترامب رونالدو لودر وهو وريث ثروه
اسلودر والذي يعرف ترامب منذ ايام الجامعه
اعلن الابتعاد عن عالم ترامب ولم يعلن من
سيدعم في 2024 لكنه في الماضي يتبرع لشركه
تابعه لمن لحكم فلوريدا روندس الذي قد
يكون ابرز منافس لترامب داخل الحزب ستيفن
شورزمان الجمهوريه البارز الذي اسمه هو
الاخر انضم للقائمه وحان الوقت اللي يتجه
الجمهورينا الى جيلا جديدا من القاده
وهكذا تصرح والدعم الذهبي
الرئيس السابق مسؤوليه الموجه الحمراء
التي لم تتحقق ابدا في 2022 واضاف للقائمه
خسائر 2018 و2020
يتزايد الجدل والانقسام بين الجمهوريين في
الكونغرس بعد نتائج انتخابات التشديد
النصفي التي وصفت بالضعيفه والفاشله لعدم
حصول موجه حمراء كما كان متوقعا عدد من
الجمهوريين يرون ان الحزب لم يستفيد من
التضخم ومن تراجع شعبيه الرئيس والتاريخ
الذي يلعب غالبا ضد حزب الرئيس ويلقون
باللوم على ترامب بسبب الاداء السيء لمن
رشحهم في المقابل ينتقدوا جمهوريون اخرون
زعيمهم في مجلس الشيوخ
الذي حمله ترامب مسؤوليه الفشل في السيطره
على المسجد
انقسام ازداد وضوحا بعد اعلان ترامب عن
ترشحه بين المعارضه ومؤيد ومن حاول
النائيه بانفسهم حتى تتضح الصوره اكثر بعد
انتهاء جوله الاعاده في جورجيا واكتماله
فرز الاصوات بالنسبه لمجلس النواب